it is finally here something that we
have all been waiting for for a very
long time now and have been talking
about for a very long time now as well
the nfinity saga and its completion
that's right the Infinity Saga
collectors complete box set has been
officially revealed and it's gonna cost
you a pretty penny the Infinity saga box
that was actually accidentally revealed
by Best Buy they accidentally put it up
on their website revealing this photo
and the date that it's going to come out
and the price according to the page on
bestbuy.com that is now removed the
Infinity Saga box set will arrive on
November 15th and it's going to sell for
five hundred and forty nine ninety nine
so five hundred and fifty dollars for
the box set now they are going to be
limited and numbered so they are
collectors items and if you don't know
the collectors box comes with all 23
Marvel Cinematic Universe movies on both
4k uhd and blu-ray the box set will also
come from a letter from Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios himself and
a matte Ferguson lithograph it will also
come with a special bonus disc with
deleted and extended scenes and as you
can see here it's definitely a super
cool collector's item and I know for
many of us these movies are a really big
part of our lives
yes 550 is a lot of money but it is a
collector's item and you do get all 23
MCU movies once this comes out I will do
a giveaway on one of these I know it's a
lot of money so I do want to get
somebody out there an opportunity to
have one who can't but let me know will
you be buying this Infinity Saga
complete box set let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below also
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
like the video and leave a comment below
to enter my current giveaway which is an
xbox one or a ps4 and if you'd also like
a chance to win in attendance which be
sure to follow me on Twitter and click
the link in the description down below
I'll play the Infinity Saga trailer
right after this and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
let's track this from the beginning
[Music]
start something pure
[Music]
something exciting
[Music]
then
do you mr. Newton
[Music]
told you okay so far you like it
I'm feeling it
why stop there
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
[Music]
this is the path I started us on
I'll bury strength
invites challenge
[Music]
challenge
sites conflict
culture
breathe catastrophe
[Music]
the thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts
[Music]
inevitable
[Music]
what a sweet-ass run it's been
EPIK forces of darkness and by
[Music]
[Applause]
universe now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you